So now that I have that,
I backed everything up and
I can just do selection again.
Now this time around because I've
changed sort of my estimates
of the Q functions along the way.
I might want to make
a different selection.
And so that actually tells us where
this original policy comes from.
This original policy is just
an estimate of two values
that I have where I happen to feel
very comfortable about those Q values.
I've visited these states many times,
I've backed up a lot of information from
them so I have a decent estimate and I'm
willing to do the kind of greedy policy
that is implied by these Q functions.
>> I see, so we're taking greedy
steps down the black part of the tree
when we hit a leaf them we
do the roll out policy pi r
to get estimates at
those different values.
Do we now know anything
new about the tree?
>> Yes, and in fact,
if we did this 100 bazillion times,
or however many number of times we sort
of wanted to, we just can say well,
I know the actions that I
can take from this node.
And so I feel comfortable in expanding
my policy all the way down to here for
this particular node as well.
And when if I did this again, and let's
say the selection algorithm had me go
here, here, here and
I got back to here again.
I would actually know which
action I wanted to take,
say it ended up with me being here.
But then once again I've gotten to
a place where I don't feel comfortable
about what to do next, and
I would do the expansion and
the rollout again, over and
over and over again.
So I just keep doing this again and
again and again and again and again and
again and again and again.
And what this gives me is an ever
expanding tree where I feel more and
more comfortable about my cue
values and, therefore more and
more comfortable about
a policy that I should take.
>> And it seems like it's
getting more accurate over time.
>> Yeah, and in fact if you're
at each of these nodes, right?
and you took those actions and
you did the expansion and
you did that well let's say
an infinite number of times, and
then you do an infinite number of
roll outs over and over again.
Eventually you would converge
to a property two value.
>> Cool that's right so this is
a planning algorithm we need to know
the transition model to be
able to do those roll outs.
>> Right, or you have to have
some way of doing the simulation.
So when you say you need to
know the transition model,
you could mean a couple of things.
You could mean I actually
have the transition model and
I can do calculations with it.
Or you could just mean I have some
way of simulating the world and
I can just sample from it.
So this is pretty neat, right?
I think it has some neat
little features to it.
It allows me to kind of
build up a model the world.
Do a bunch of simulation and
figure out what to do.
But there are a couple of questions
that should pop out to you even
though I kind of ran
over them fairly quickly.
I think the first one is,
well, when do you stop?
What does this actually, I mean,
this is kind of an inner
loop of a process, right?
I'm at this state I
have an estimate of Q
values that I'm comfortable
enough in that I'm going to take
actual actions following
the policy that's implied by them.
And then I'm going to keep expanding and
learning more and more about it.
Well in principle I could
just do that for eternity.
But at some point you have to stop.
And when do you stop?
Well you stop when you get bored.
>> And what do you do when you stop?
>> Well, once you stop so next
question well what I do after I stop?
Well, you execute.
You do a sort of one step policy
based upon what you've learned and
then you throw it all away and
you do it all over again.
>> Wait, so
you take that step in the world
using policy the whole
chain that you figured out?
>> Well, you could but and
in fact sometimes I mean,
well you can do actually
any number of things there.
But sort of the simplest version of this
is I started out with an empty tree.
I'm in some particular state,
I'm going to hallucinate all
the things that I might do from there.
As I do that I'll be learning more and
more about the world.
This will allow me to do better and
better exploration
because I do this kind of Monte Carlo
search and simulation and hallucination.
And then eventually I learn enough that
I know what the right thing to do is
from this state and then I do it.
And then I end up wherever it is
I end up in the real world and
when I'm asked to do something
again I just do it all over again.
>> Wow, so it does a lot of
thinking each time it takes a step.
>> Yeah but
it's very fast thinking because
you know I'm just flipping coins.
If I have a fast simulator and I'm
able to do addition pretty quickly and
maybe some averaging I can actually
do this estimate fairly well.
What's going to impact this a lot
is sort of how far down I can go
before I run out of computational power?
Typically that's what board
really means board means okay
I've taken 15 seconds that's too much
time or maybe I've taken three seconds.
That's too much time it's time to do
the best thing that I can based upon
what I know.
But if I can do that every single time,
if I can expand this tree pretty
deeply at every time step,
then I lose 50 milliseconds.
But 50 milliseconds is a long time for
a computer and not any time at all for
human beings.
And the alternative would be to
actually explore the entire space and
try to solve the underlying MDP.
And if you have a whole
lot of states and
a whole lot of actions then that
can take a very, very long time.
So do you take 50 or 200 milliseconds
every time you take an action and
do it online?
Or do you take three and a half months
of super computing power to figure out
the optimal policy and then use that?
And the answer is, it depends.